We're on problem 36.
They've drawn a little
graph here.
So let's draw it up
for ourselves.
So that's the y-axis.
That is the x-axis.
And then they have this point.
Let's see, minus 1.
They say, 1, 2, 3.
Let's see.
1, 2.
And then they have this line
segment PQ that goes
from 0, minus 1.
Let me draw that in
a different color.
It goes from 0, minus
1 to 3 comma 2.
So it goes from there, so
3, so roughly there.
I think that's about as
good as I can do.
And the way they drew it,
it intersects 1 here.
And so this would be 3.
This is the point 3 comma 2.
And they say in the figure
above, the point on segment
PQ, so they say this is point
P, this is point Q.
The point on PQ that is twice
as far from P as from Q.
So the point is on this segment,
so this point is
someplace around here.
We could find points that are
away from the segment that are
twice as far from P as
from Q, but they say
it's on this segment.
So let's think about
it a little bit.
If we just look at how do we
get from P to Q, we go 3 to
the right, right? x increases
by 3 and y
increases by 3, right?
So if we wanted to go 2/3 along
the way, what if we just
increased x by 2 to get to x is
equal to 2 and increased y
by 2, right?
So the x's and y's only
increase by 2/3
of the way to Q.
So then that would
be the point.
x is 2 and then y is 1.
That would be the point
2 comma 1, which is B.
Next question.
37.
If a positive integer n is
divisible by both 5 and 7,
than n must be divisible by
which of the following?
Let's see, they give
us a couple of
choices: I, II and III.
So they say it has to
be divisible by 12.
No, that's not the case.
35 is divisible by 5 and 7.
It's not divisible by 12.
35.
Well, sure.
If you're divisible by 5 and
7, that means it's equal to
some constant times
5 times 7, right?
And this could be a bunch of
numbers multiplied together.
But that means it's equal to 35
times some other integer,
and that integer could have
a bunch of other factors.
So, right.
It has to be divisible by 35.
And statement III is 70.
Well, no, 35 is divisible
by 5 and 7, but it's not
divisible by 70.
So statement III is not right.
So it's II only.
So that's C.
Question 38.
If 4 is one solution to the
equation x squared plus 3x
plus k is equal to 10,
so 4 is one solution.
So that means if I were to
factor this, it'll be x minus
4 times x plus or minus
something else, because we
know that x minus 4 equals 0,
which tells us that x is equal
to 4 is one of the solutions.
So what are they going
to ask us?
They're going to say, where k
is a constant, what is the
other solution?
So let's think about
it a little bit.
Well, actually, let me rewrite
it a little different.
I didn't realize that they
said this is equal to 10.
So let's subtract 10
from both sides.
We get x squared plus 3x-- you
essentially want to find the
roots of this quadratic-- plus
k minus 10 is equal to 0.
And you want to factor
it, right?
You could factor
any quadratic.
It's going to be x plus
a times x plus b.
And they're telling us
that 4 is one of
the solutions, right?
4 is one of the solutions,
so minus 4 could be a.
So this would be x minus 4 times
some other number, x
plus b, is equal to 0.
And I said positive
4 in the solution.
Why did I put a minus 4 here?
Because think about it.
If we factor this quadratic and
we get this, that's tells
us either x minus 4 is
0 or x plus b is 0.
If x minus 4 is 0, then the
solution is x is equal to 4,
so that's why I wrote
x minus 4 there.
But anyway, let's figure
out what b could be.
So if we multiply this out to
try to pattern match it with
this, we get x times x is x
squared minus 4x plus b times
x, and then you have minus
4 times b, so minus 4b.
So then this is equal to x
squared, and then we could
write it plus b minus
4 times x.
I just factored an x out of
these two terms, right?
And so you get b minus 4
minus 4b is equal to 0.
So now you just pattern
match it.
You say b minus 4-- x squared
equals x squared.
b minus 4x has to be
equal to 3x, right?
We're just pattern matching.
That's the only first-degree
x term there.
So b minus 4 has to be equal--
x has to be equal to 3x.
We don't even care about k.
So b minus 4 has to be equal
to 3, or b is equal to 7.
Oh, right, right.
So they want to know what
the other solution is.
They don't want to
know what b is.
And I was looking and
was like, oh, wow,
there isn't a 7 there.
There's a negative 7.
So that tells us that the
factorization of this
problem-- I would have gotten
that wrong if they put a 7
there, because I wasn't
careful-- is x minus 4 times x
plus 7 is equal to 0, right?
So we already said we could say
x minus 4 is equal to 0.
And that's where we get
the 4 solution.
Or we could say x plus
7 is equal to 0.
Subtract 7 from both sides.
The other solution is x
is equal to minus 7.
That was a careless mistake I
almost made, but I got saved
by the choices.
So that's choice A.
Next problem.
39.
If x is equal to negative
3, what is the
value of minus 3x squared?
So I don't know, maybe they're
trying to test your ability to
do order of operations
or something.
So this is equal to minus 3
times minus three squared,
right? x squared.
So this is equal to minus
3 times positive 9.
Minus 3 squared is positive 9,
which equals minus 27, which
is choice A.
Next question.
40.
29 squared plus 29, over
29 is equal to?
Well, let's just divide
the numerator and the
denominator by 29.
What's 29 squared?
This is the same thing as 29
squared over 29 plus-- I'm
just going to separate these
two terms out-- plus 29/29.
29 squared divided by 29.
x squared divided by x is x.
29 squared divided
by 29 is 29.
29 divided by 29 is 1,
so it equals 30.
So that is choice E.
Problem 41.
If x is equal to 1 minus 3t and
y is equal to 2t minus 1.
So I'm going to write
it like this.
minus 1 plus 2t.
I just want to put the t's
under each other, right?
2t minus 1.
For what value of t
does x equal y?
OK, so let's just set x equal
y and solve for t.
So we could just say if x is
equal to y, we get 1 minus 3t
has to equal this, which
is 2t minus 1.
Let's add 3t to both sides.
So you get 1-- 3t goes
away from there--
equals 5t, minus 1.
Add 1 to both sides.
You get 2 is equal to 5t.
Divide both sides by 5.
You get t is equal to 5/2,
which is choice A.
And I'm almost out of time.
The next one has a diagram,
which always takes me some
time to draw, so I'll see
you in the next video.